bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
ici au parlement européen à bruxelles
dans cette émission nous allons parler
du gaspillage alimentaire nous allons
aller à londres voir ce que les
britanniques font en la matière et à
paris kathia gilder recevra guillaume
garot il est le ministre français
délégué à l'agroalimentaire mais la
question de la semaine c'est le budget
européen
les responsables européens sont en train
de s'écharper sur la question alors
l'europe va-t-elle dans le mur
c'est la question posée par nora hamadi
en période de disette voici les 27 à
table pour discuter gros sous avec au
menu une question car cayenne comment
boucler le budget de l'union quand tous
les états se serre la ceinture
derrière les sourires de circonstance
ça grince entre les partisans d'une
augmentation de l' enveloppe et les
autres les autres
david cameron entre autres comme à son
habitude le premier ministre britannique
a mis les pieds dans le lard sa
proposition un gel du budget une
position refusée par son propre
parlement qui demande lui une réduction
pure et simple alors comme souvent dans
l'union la situation vire au vaudeville
en gala merkel menace d'annuler un
sommet extraordinaire consacré à la
question puis entame une tournée
européenne pour tenter un déblocage
pendant ce temps dans les couloirs on
s'agite on palabre on tergiverse 50
milliards 100 milliards c'est la chasse
au rabais sur le budget européen mais un
budget de djata l'heure il faut relancer
l'économie
quelle idée
en même temps au sud de bruxelles
les grecs entament leur énième grève
générale contre un énième budget
d'austérité dans l'indifférence générale
alors ce budget il va dans le mur alors
nous sommes sur ce plateau avec alain
lamassoure bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen vous êtes président de
la commission du budget ici au parlement
européen il va y avoir un sommet dans
quelques jours un sommet européen ici à
bruxelles
est-ce que ce sommet qui sera consacrée
justement au budget européen est ce que
ce sommet va déboucher sur un accord
mais je souhaite qu'ils débouchent sur
un accord soit ce sommet soit le suivant
ce sera une question difficile sur un
accord qui est de l'europe avancer
l'europe un budget famille européenne un
budget familial qui est tout petit qui
représente 1% du produit intérieur brut
européen environ 130 milliards d'euros
30 à 40 % du budget national français ce
budget pour des raisons historiques est
consacré pour 40% à aider les
agriculteurs en cas de la politique
agricole commune pour 40% aux
investissements régionaux du fonds
régionaux pour 10% la politique
étrangère et 10% seulement aux
investissements d'avenir à l'innovation
à la recherche aux grandes
infrastructures de transports et des
communications qui sont évidemment les
actions dont nous avons besoin pour
retrouver la compétitivité et la
croissance
depuis la crise de la dette depuis trois
ans les dirigeants européens ont déployé
les efforts pour aider les pays en
difficulté à sortir de la crise le
malade est à l'hôpital il est sous
perfusion à travers le fond qu'on
appelle mécanisme européen de stabilité
le balad a pris des engagements
désormais de mieux s'alimenter et d'être
à la diète
c'est le traité budgétaire bon mais
maintenant la question qui va se poser
quand le malade va sortir de l'hôpital
c'est comment on en refait une athlète
capable sur la scène internationale de
lutter à armes égales avec l'athlète
chinois américains etc
ça c'est le rôle du budget européen si
nous savons faire en sorte que un
maximum de crédits soit consacrée à une
surréaction d'avenir si on reprend votre
votre allégorie c'est que les états
européens n'ont pas du tout envie de
payer pour l'hôpital ils ont pas du tout
envie de payer ensuite pour l'athlète
voilà alors vous avez mis le doigt sur
le défaut du budget européen
c'est qu'il n'a pas de ressources
propres le budget européen est financé
par les vingt-sept budgets nationaux
c'est exactement comme si il y avait 27
contribuables pour financer le budget
européen
c'est un système qui aboutit à l'impasse
actuelle puisque les vingt-sept budget
nationaux sont quasiment ruinées et donc
aucun ministre du budget ne veut
augmenter ses impôts ou sa dette pour
augmenter sa participation budget
européen
c'est pourquoi le parlement européen se
bat depuis plusieurs années et est
arrivé à faire reconnaître le principe
selon lequel les dépenses européennes
doivent être financées par des
ressources européennes
il faut couper le lien entre budgets
nationaux et budget européen l'assemblée
enfin on en est pas encore on n'allait
pas encore là et ont encore une fois
dans quelques jours ya ce sommet pensait
que à la fin de ce sommet qui pourrait
d'ailleurs durer visiblement trois jours
je crois qu'on dit un sommet à trois
chemises puisque il durera trois jours
est ce que pense qu'il y aura un accord
ou est ce que les dirigeants vont se
séparer sur un constat d'échec
je suis pas un pronostiqueur sportif moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que les
dirigeants se comportent en dirigeants
et non pas en sous secrétaire d'état au
budget et que chacun se demande le
président français la chancelière
allemande le le le les premiers
ministres italien espagnol et les autres
dans cette période on sortant de la
crise où nous devons retrouver la
compétitivité ou pour relancer la
croissance en europe nous avons besoin
d'atteindre une masse critique pour un
certain nombre de grands investissements
d'avenir qu'est ce que nous attendons du
budget européen
quel doit être son montant à quoi on le
consacre et comment le finance et sur la
manière de trouver des ressources
propres il ya deux propositions sur la
table qu'on va examiner dont on va
débattre premièrement la taxe sur les
transactions financières il ya
maintenant une moitié de pays qui sont
tout à fait favorables
qu'on crée une taxe sur les transactions
financières qui pourrait venir alimenter
directement le budget européen est une
nouvelle forme de tva qui pour un taux
très faible pourrait également alimenter
le budget européen
à ce moment là nous pourrons trouver des
moyens de financement
si ça n'est pas le cas et si chacun se
contentent d'essayer de minimiser sa
contribution aux gestionnaires ceux qui
regardent deux pays et de maximiser ce
qu'il en retire par exemple
traditionnellement la france se bat
uniquement sur l'agriculture
bon tant mieux pour nos agriculteurs
sauf que l'enjeu des dix ans qui
viennent
si on veut que la france retrouve sa
compétivité c'est pas simplement
l'agriculture la position française
justement une question est ce que la
position française est clair aujourd'hui
elle l'était avec nicolas sarkozy on
était d'accord ou pas d'accord mais elle
était clair est-ce qu'avec françois
hollande vous ici à bruxelles au
parlement européen vous comprenez sur le
budget quelle est la position française
elle est incompréhensible
elle est complètement contradictoire et
donc à l'heure où nous parlons je
souhaite que ça change
à l'heure où nous parlons elle ne pèse
pas que dit la france il faut geler le
budget européen jusqu'en 2020 ce que
disait nicolas sarkozy déjà ses lacets
la suite ce que des classes oui je
dirais il était dans une période
électorale
aujourd'hui la position de la france
comme de l'allemagne comme du premier
britannique sait on gèle jusqu'en 2020
et mais à l'intérieur de ce gène il faut
maintenir l'argent pour l'agriculture il
faut maintenir l'argent pour les régions
puissent toutes les régions françaises
sont dirigées par des socialistes
et puis il faut essayer de faire plus
pour les dépenses d'avenir c'est
totalement contradictoire
je souhaite que la france fasse le bon
choix qui est la priorité à l'avenir
alors vous avez mis le doigt sur un
sujet entre guillemets qui fait mal en
tout cas un programme qui est très
populaire à programme européen très
populaire qui s'appelle erasmus et vous
avez dit il ya quelques jours que si on
continuait comme ça ce programme erasmus
ne seraient plus financées ça fait
évidemment beaucoup de bruit en europe
les télévisions européennes se sont
emparés de ce sujet je propose de
regarder ce zapping signé aurélie la
face
9 milliards d'euros
c'est ce qu'il manque pour financer les
programmes d'éducation et en particulier
erasmus la commission sont inquiètes
fonctionne athlètes délai heureusement
mba state
nous avons donné assez d'argent aux
états membres pour couvrir les frais de
scolarité jusqu'à la fin 2012 mais pour
le futur nous avons besoin d'un
amendement plus précisément jeu nous
avons besoin de plus d'argent pour
assurer la mise en place de la mobilité
étudiante en 2013 le programme populaire
même si les coupes budgétaires menace 3
millions d'étudiants en 25 ans est une
destination favorite au sud de l'europe
l'espagne est le pays qui reçoit plus de
30 mille étudiants européens chaque
année comme olga qui vient d'angleterre
et mathias du danemark l'espagne pays
attractif mais pays en crise alors à
l'annoncé de cette nouvelle réduction
budgétaire les espagnols sont les
premiers européens à réagir les
étudiants erasmus qui arrive en espagne
trouve une éducation avec encore
quelques moyens mais si les coupes
budgétaires continue comme ça il n'y
aura bientôt plus rien
sans compter le climat social très tendu
vraiment défavorables même si les
d'erasmus ne dépasse pas les 160 euros
par mois sans ce coup de pouce certains
craignent qu'à l'avenir ces études ne
soit réservé qu'à une élite
bon alors il reste plus assez l'auberge
espagnole ce film qu'on connaît tous
c'est peut-être ce qui participe
d'ailleurs de la création d'un sentiment
européen chez les jeunes vous avez fait
fort en mettant en avant le fait que les
races plus ce serait peut-être plus
financé bon c'était une position
médiatique j'ai envie à ce qu'il ya une
réelle menace est ce que erasmus
pourrait ne plus avoir d'argent erasmus
n'a plus d'argent depuis le 1er octobre
d'ici la fin de l'année 2012
il n'y a plus un euro de plus pour
erasmus et nous sommes en train de
négocier avec les ministres du budget
pour faire en sorte que non seulement
sur erasmus qui est un programme très
important pour l'esprit européen pour la
formation des jeunes comme vous l'avez
rappelé mais qui
quantitativement la relativement faible
c'est un milliard d'euros sur 130
milliards mais cette absence de crédit
vaut aussi pour des programmes sensibles
en plus important du point de vue du
montant tout le fonds social européen
tout le programme ka de recherche
européens le fonds de développement
rural et même l'aide humanitaire n'a
plus un rond jusqu'au 31 décembre
et donc il est temps que les
gouvernements c'est ce double langage
dans lequel quand on se réunit au niveau
des grands chefs conseil européen on dit
il faut soutenir la croissance et en
juin dernier sur la proposition du
président hollande
le conseil européen décide de consacrer
100 1 milliard d'euros de moyens
supplémentaires pour soutenir la
croissance
trois mois après il ya plus d'argent
pour erasmus pour le fonds social pour
l'aide humanitaire
il faut arrêter ce scandale il faut
qu'elle masque tombe nous avons besoin
de ces crédits des engagements étaient
pris des jeunes ont été envoyés faire
une partie de leurs études dans
l'université d'un pays différent il faut
naturellement que les bourses au pays
alors vous n'étiez plus d'argent dans
les rasmussen en tout cas ça concerne
pas de tout de suite ça sera peut-être
pour l'année prochaine mais en tout cas
pour les jeunes qui sont déjà partis
dans le cas de la flandre ont leur
bourse parce que l' agence installée à
bordeaux qui gère le programme
c'était un peu mes filles avaient vu
venir le coup est assez constituer un
petit matelas
les étudiants français sont pas menacés
mais vous avez entendu dans le reportage
en spy en espagne manifestement il ya
une pénurie de crédit dès maintenant
alors une question sur l'élection
américaine barack obama vient d'être
réélu à la tête des états unis est ce
que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
l'union européenne c'est une bonne
nouvelle en ce sens qu'on préfère
travailler avec des gens qu'on connaît
ce qu'avec avec ce qu'on ne connaît pas
le nom de vieillir sans pas des non non
on ne peut pas dire que barack obama
était un grand président américain qu'il
était un grand président sur la scène
internationale et on ne peut pas dire
qu'il était un grand ami de l'europe
cela dit naturellement nous
travaillerons avec lui et je dirais moi
en tant que français la leçon je tire de
cette élection c'est que la démagogie
d'extrême droite exprimé par mitt romney
n'est pas payante même en période de
crise ça c'est une pédagogie que je vais
faire de mon côté en france je voudrais
en profiter pour dire que la bonne
nouvelle pour les européens peut-être
surprendre les téléspectateurs c'est que
la prochaine grande élection de ce type
aura lieu en europe dans toute l'europe
dans 18 mois
nous allons pour la première fois grâce
au dernier traité européen le traité de
lisbonne élire un président du pouvoir
exécutif européen la commission
européenne au suffrage universel lors de
la prévert l'élection du parlement
européen en juin 2014 le parlement
européen sera réélu et cette fois ci le
président de la commission qui jusqu'à
présent était désigné comme on nomme un
haut fonctionnaire international le
secrétaire-général de l'onu ou directeur
général du fmi par un accord entre les
gouvernements le succès surprise en
barroso sera élu par nos tous les 500
millions de citoyens européens et nous
allons assister à des face-à-face
télévisé entre les candidats des deux
grands partis politiques européens
le parti de droite le ppe les
socialistes européens qui s'y prépare
dès maintenant et nous allons j'espère
avoir une véritable autorité politique
un véritable président européen élu au
suffrage universel en 18 mois si les
médias européens consacrent autant de
temps et d'énergie aux élections
européennes que l'on fait pour les
élections américaines à la mention merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
nous allons parler maintenant d'un autre
sujet c'est celui du gaspillage
alimentaire c'est un problème européen
il se trouve qu il ya un pays qui a fait
beaucoup d'efforts là dessus
c'est le royaume uni nous allons partir
pour un reportage à londres avec flora
sauvage et ensuite nous irons à paris
retrouvé kathia gilder et son invité
guillaume garot qui est ministre délégué
à l'agroalimentaire et qui nous
présentera le plan français tout de
suite donc direction londres avec laura
sauvage
chaque année en grande bretagne 15
millions de tonnes de nourriture sont
jetés à la poubelle la moitié provient
des ménages civ
essai de gaspiller le moins possible et
malgré tout il lui arrive de gâcher de
la nourriture
parfois c'est difficile de s'y retrouver
cette salade par exemple va peut-être
finir à la poubelle ou au compost on
congèle le pain pour faire des toasts
parce que c'est difficile de s'y
retrouver sinon depuis quatre ans la
mairie d'arrondissement de steve a mis à
sa disposition une poubelle destinée à
recueillir ses déchets alimentaires
voici mes poubelles
jean ligne pour les déchets une autre
pour le recyclage et une autre pour la
nourriture à la mairie la luge à notre
disposition gratuitement
je peux y mettre tous les déchets
alimentaires légumes fruits viandes
poissons tout y passe
l'objectif du gouvernement britannique
est de réduire le gaspillage alimentaire
de 700 mille tonnes d'ici 2015
car il ya urgence il y a eu un réel
effort au royaume uni pour réduire le
gaspillage alimentaire
on a à peu près la même population qu'en
france nous sommes 63 millions mais le
royaume uni est beaucoup plus petit en
superficie particulièrement à londres où
l'on et 8 millions donc il faut vraiment
qu'on fasse attention car on n'a pas
assez de place pour incinérer nos
déchets
tristram stuart est un fervent militant
contre le gaspillage alimentaire
il organise dans les capitales
européennes des buffets gratuits avec
des ingrédients destinés à être jetés
pour mobiliser les consommateurs sur le
gaspi les consommateurs britanniques
jette environ 20 pour cent de la
nourriture qu'ils à chaque fois un
certain nombre d'initiatives ont été
mises en place pour réduire le
gaspillage dans les foyers des dans
l'industrie on a ainsi vu une réduction
de 13% du gaspillage des ménages ce qui
est plutôt positive
maintenant on met la pression sur
l'industrie
car les supermarchés britanniques
produisent trois cent mille tonnes de
déchets alimentaires par an certains ont
pris le problème à bras le corps ils
font la chasse au gaspi les offres
promotionnelles sur les produits qui
approche de la date de péremption ont
permis à la chaîne de supermarchés marks
and spencer de réduire son gaspillage
alimentaire de 40% plus depuis qu'ils
ont mis en place cette initiative en
2008 d'après tristram stuart un tiers de
la production alimentaire mondiale est
jeté à la poubelle alors même qu'un
milliard d'êtres humains sur la planète
ne mange pas à sa faim à spidah field le
plus vieux marché londonien
neuf restaurants gaspille chaque année
200 mille tonnes de nourriture face à ce
constat
andres felipe ramirez a été engagé par
le centre commercial pour limiter ce
gaspillage
voici l'arrière des restaurants sexe ici
il ya différentes sections on a des
poubelles exploit pour la nourriture le
livre ait là sa principale arrive à un
restaurant asiatique is likely ici c'est
le potentiel du recyclage de la
nourriture est énorme
on peut produire de l'engrais ou de
l'électricité en recyclant la nourriture
qu'on jette et on empêche au passage que
ces déchets des effets toxiques sur
l'environnement
dans cette usine du sud de londres on
recycle les déchets alimentaires pour
produire de l'engrais destinés aux
agriculteurs de la région
salade poisson pain de mie les déchets
collectés ici viennent des restaurants
des supermarchés ou encore des maisons
des alentours
ces céréales ne sont pas périmés mais
elles ont été jetés à la poubelle
c'est tout à fait mangeable ce produit
se périment l'année prochaine mais il ya
peut-être un problème de bactéries
expliquerai que ces céréales ont été
jetés bien tout simplement peut-être y
at-il un défaut aux durées de
l'emballage et le fabricant a préféré
tout jeter plutôt que le consommateur
achète un produit avec un emballage
depuis 2002 en grande bretagne la
directive de l'union européenne sur la
mise en décharge des déchets fixe des
objectifs de recyclage et de
valorisation
dès lors une réelle prise de conscience
a eu lieu notre moteur principal c'est
la directive européenne sur les déchets
malheureusement on est loin d'approcher
les objectifs que la directive nous
impose on risque donc d'avoir une amende
de l'union européenne si on ne parvient
pas à réaliser ses objectifs et les
denrées alimentaires sont l'une des
choses les plus faciles à recycler
près de la moitié des aliments encore
sains sont gaspillées chaque année par
les ménages et les supermarchés de
l'union européenne alors que 79 millions
d'européens vivant en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
l'objectif de l'union européenne est de
réduire son gaspillage alimentaire de
50% d'ici à 2025
bonjour monsieur le ministre jours merci
de nous recevoir
in situ dans votre bureau à paris pour
cette émission d'europe hebdo consacré
au gaspillage alimentaire alors on peut
citer ce chiffre impressionnant plus
d'un tiers de la production alimentaire
mondiale serait jetée à la poubelle
alors qu'un milliard d'êtres humains ne
mange pas à sa faim
en europe aussi en gaspille beaucoup
outre-manche
nos amis britanniques ont trouvé
quelques solutions et le gouvernement
veut réduire le gaspillage de 700 mille
tonnes d'ici 2015 la grande bretagne at
elle une heure d'avancé sur la france en
tout cas il ya des pays européens qui
aujourd'hui vont d'avant et la france
veut être dans ce train de tête parce
que chacun de nous aujourd'hui en france
ge est de 20 à 30 kg de nourriture
chaque année c'est d'abord une perte de
pouvoir d'achat
ce sont des euros qu'on met à la
poubelle et on l'a évalué à peu près 500
euros par année pour une famille de
quatre personnes dont il ya d'abord un
enjeu économique
et puis il ya aussi un enjeu de valeur
parce que vous l'avez dit au moment où
tant d'êtres humains grève de la faim ou
dépendent de l'aide alimentaire
eh bien il faut s'engager concrètement
pour lutter contre les dérives de la
société de surconsommation c'est ce que
nous faisons
vous proposez un impact national anti
gaspillage
si vous en donner les grandes lignes qui
cible et vous en priorité le
consommateur ou plutôt la grande
distribution s'agit de cibler personne
mais d'engager chacun ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui si nous voulons concrètement
efficacement lutter contre le gaspillage
alimentaire il faut que chacun s'engage
chacun sait qui en est fait
les citoyens les consommateurs mais ce
sont aussi tous les acteurs de la chaîne
alimentaire des producteurs jusqu'aux
distributeurs en passant par les
transformateurs
sans oublier les associations de
solidarité qui joue un grand rôle pour
lutter contre les gaspillages
est ce que tous ces acteurs sont prêts à
entendre vos arguments je crois mais
santé mobiliser derrière jouera je les
rencontre depuis que j'ai engagé cette
initiative contre le gaspillage et il ya
une vraie volonté de faire mouvement
ensemble et c'est la condition de la
réussite que ensemble nous affichions
des objectifs et que ensemble nous
agissions donc c'est ça l'idée de ce
pacte
c'est d'engager des actions concrètes
alors concrètes ça veut dire dans la
restauration collective par exemple et
avec le conseil général de la dordogne
nous allons faire en sorte que dans les
collèges on puisse réduire le gaspillage
alimentaire donc oui il ya une dimension
éducative avec les enfants mais on va
aussi travailler en mayenne dans mon
département pour que avec un foyer de
restauration collective pour pour
adultes pour jeunes adultes on puisse là
aussi adapter les besoins aux vrais
portion aux justes proportions
voilà ce qui compte aujourd'hui alors ça
c'est une zone test si j'ai bien compris
et quel calendrier de l'application de
ces mesures ce que vous allez mettre en
place en dordogne par exemple toutes ces
actions sont lancés au fur et à mesure
elles seront évaluées au printemps
prochain au mois d'avril et au mois de
juin
nous signerons ce pacte national contre
le gaspillage alimentaire avec
l'ensemble des acteurs
pourquoi cette démarche progressive
parce que il faut créer une dynamique et
une dynamique collective contre le
gaspillage alors j'ai parlé de la
restauration collective
nous pourrions parler aussi des marchés
d'intérêt national vous savez là où
comme à rungis
les producteurs viennent vendre leurs
leur production est bien avec les
associations de solidarité nous allons
récupérer les invendus pour les
retraités immédiatement dans l'aide
alimentaire là aussi une façon concrète
de lutter contre le gaspillage donc au
fur et à mesure tous les acteurs que
j'ai cités seront mobilisés et au mois
de juin ce sera cette réunion nationale
contre le gaspillage alimentaire pour
revenir à la grande distribution
quels moyens avez-vous concrètement de
leur faire appliquer ce pattes alors
même que certaines enseignes peuvent
inciter les consommateurs à acheter en
grande quantité vu qu'il ya souvent des
offres promotionnelles des choses comme
ça dit un vrai levier d'action vous avez
raison et vous savez que la grande
distribution est aujourd'hui mobilisée
dans ce pacte national le futur pacte
national contre le gaspillage alors
concrètement quelle forme ça peut
prendre d'abord ça peut être la vente à
l'unité en particulier pour les produits
laitiers c'est ce qu'on cite le plus
souvent aujourd'hui un tiers des
français vivent seuls donc il faut aussi
adapter l'offre dans les magasins la
réalité de la consommation donc là
dessus nous allons avancer avec
certaines grandes marques de la
distribution et puis nous allons
travailler aussi c'est une idée qui
avait été lancé d'ailleurs par nos amis
anglais à ce qu'on appelle les
promotions différé ça veut dire que pour
trois produits payés au prix de 2 et
bien vous prenez la première semaine les
deux premiers produits et puis vous avez
troisième la semaine suivante ce qui
vous évite de gaspiller
donc voyez concrètement petit à petit
mais avec beaucoup de détermination nous
allons pouvoir lutter contre le
gaspillage
moi j'ai fixé un objectif ambitieux 1
c'est celui qui a indiqué d'ailleurs le
parlement européen de réduire de moitié
le gaspillage alimentaire en france
d'ici 2025
alors justement comment se situe la
france par rapport à ses autres
partenaires actuellement avant la mise
en oeuvre de votre plan plutôt de bons
ou mauvais élèves nous sommes plutôt bon
élève par rapport à d'autres pays
européens
nous sommes plutôt bien placé mais là
encore nous avons des marges de
progression
1 et si nous pouvons améliorer les
choses nous le ferons c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai proposé cet objectif
ambitieux pour 2025 mais nous serons
d'autant plus efficace que partout en
europe il y aura ce mouvement contre le
gaspillage alimentaire et là où c'est
intéressant c'est que ça n'est pas
simplement les politiques qu'ils se
saisissent du dossier on voit bien
partout des associations des citoyens se
mobiliser pour dire maintenant on arrête
le gaspillage
on y va et bien tous ensemble à lyon xi
alors en grande bretagne tristram stuart
et partir en guerre contre contre le
gaspillage
il dit que bon que beaucoup de
gouvernements européens l'ont sollicité
pour trouver des solutions à ce que vous
êtes entré en contact aussi avec lui ce
que vous l'avez rencontrée eh bien ça
fait partie des rendez vous que je veux
savoir pour finaliser l'ensemble
des actions mais d'ores et déjà ce qui
vaut pour moi c'est aussi de repérer
partout sur le territoire national ces
initiatives qui existent et qui
permettent de lutter jour après jour
contre le gaspillage les mettre en
valeur de les mettre en lumière de telle
sorte que ce qui se fait de bien aussi
sur nos territoires en france puissent
être reproduits généralisée ailleurs ça
passe aussi par une mobilisation de
chaque citoyen comme vous et moi avec
par exemple une modification des
pratiques consommé au jour le jour
plutôt que d'acheter en grande quantité
avec le risque de jeter c'est aussi des
actions comme ça qui est bien sûr faire
beaucoup bien sûr il a convaincu c'est
que que chacun y est prêt finalement et
pour ça nous avons nous voulu simplifier
faciliter la vie des citoyens nous avons
créé un site un site sur lequel vous
pouvez vous rendre avec des initiatives
des bonnes idées qui permettent tout
simplement de mieux gérer son
réfrigérateur et essaie des choses
simples mais par des choses simples et
bien on y arrive et si la mobilisation
est collective elle sera d'autant plus
efficace
donc c'est le sens aussi de ce site que
je veux très participatif gaspillage
alimentaire point fr c'est ça le nom du
site avec notamment une campagne virale
qui démarre assez fort ça de l'amusante
qui est pas culpabilisante mais qui est
fait pour pour appeler chacun à cette
prise de conscience
1 c'est très important et puis qui
montre que ne pas gaspiller c'est pas
être triste au contraire c'est une
nouvelle façon d'être de consommer c'est
pas moins acheté moins consommer c'est
mieux acheter mieux consommer c'est fait
avec beaucoup d'humour
c'est vrai eh bien merci beaucoup
monsieur mairie ou de nous avoir reçus
chez vous à paris merci à vous de votre
fidélité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour d'autres actualités
européenne passé une très bonne semaine
sur les chaînes parlementaires
nous
à